okay we want to find the area of this
hexagon and they're only giving us the
side lengths of 20 inches how do we find
the area well the first step you want to
do is you want to divide this regular
hexagon up into congruent triangles so
that's what we're gonna do here first
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to focus in on one of these
triangles so if we can find the area of
this triangle we can multiply it by 6
since there's six of them to find the
total area but the first thing we want
to do is we want to find out how much is
this central angle right here well we
know in a circle that's 360 degrees but
since there are six triangles let's
divide this by 6 so each of these
central angles is going to be 60 degrees
now if we take a look at this triangle
down here this is a 60 degree angle if
we drop a perpendicular okay which is
called the apothem here that's gonna
split this angle in half so now it's
going to be 30 degrees in 30 degrees
it's also going to bisect the base so
each one of these is going to be 10
inches but how do we find the height of
this triangle the apothem well you can
see we've got a 30 60 90 degree triangle
and just a quick refresher under 30 60
90 degree triangles the side across from
the 30-degree angle we call access the
short leg the side across from the
60-degree angle that's our longer leg
that's X square root of 3 and the one
across from the right angle that's our
longest side that's 2x so here you can
see that this is going to be across from
the 30 that's our X side 10 the longer
leg the one across from the 60-degree
angle is going to be 10 times the square
root of 3 so if we want to find the area
of this triangle which is this bottom
triangle right here we just have to do
area equals 1/2 the base okay so the
base is 20 times the height which is 10
square root of 3 and then all we have to
do is multiply by 6 since we have 6 of
these triangles so we're gonna multiply
by 6 so let's see we've got 1/2 of 20 is
10 times 6 is 60 times 10 root 3 is 600
square root of 3 inches squared since
its area if you want to see another
example check out the video I did right
there and if you want to memorize some
formulas here you can use this one
one-half apothem times pyramid
or 1/2 base times height times the
number of triangles